- Fake environments.
When you live in a world
that you can't afford
because you're keeping
up with the Joneses.
Scary shit.
Poison.
Lot of people running
their big credit cards here
to look right in their environment.
("Imminent Freestyle" by Aes Waves)
♪ Look what I did I lived my life ♪
♪ All from ideas ♪
♪ I'm going in ♪
♪ Not fitting in ♪
♪ Designing my story and filling it in ♪
♪ Imminent ♪
♪ Yeah you know that's imminent ♪
- Hello, hi, how are you?
It's a pleasure.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
- Jasmine.
- Hi Jasmine.
- My sister Liz, Rysa, DuRock.
So far, so good.
We just got here a couple hours ago.
Unlike any other CEO of any organization
that has 500 plus employees,
in marketing client
services, in social media,
none of them are practitioners.
They're executives.
- So you're creating your own content?
- At a scale greater than almost
every other human on earth.
Thus allowing me to
have unbelievable amount
of information and IP into
what's actually happening.
And the other thing that I think.
And that's the ego part.
And then on the humility part,
what I understand is just
'cause something works for me
it may not work for GE or SAP, or Pepsi.
And so I've been able to
synthesize the ability
to understand what works for an individual
whose a 42 year old male in New York,
has this kind of style.
I'm able to synthesize what would happen
if that was a 22 year
old female in Malaysia.
Whether that's a Fortune 500 SAS company,
whether that's a bottle of water.
That interpretation of big
data is a talent of mine.
- Could I trouble you for a quick photo?
- No problem.
- [Photographer] One, two and three.
Nice.
- We got it, perfect.
Alright.
- Thank you so much.
- Nice.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you so much guys.
Thank you my friend.
Thank you.
Such a pleasure.
Sit, sit, sit.
- A little bit of Malaysian hospitality.
- Oh thank you very much.
- But it's not Malaysian tea.
But it's made from Malaysia.
It's a royal slango.
- Thank you.
- Do open it at some point.
- Okay.
- Something different.
But it's a royal slango,
made from the tin.
Malaysia was famous for its tin.
- Yes.
(speaking foreign language)
Thank you.
I love it.
I don't think you have this collection.
- [Gary] I do not.
- [Host] In the form of the royal slango.
I'm gonna have to get this on the shelf.
- [Host] For Instagram and everything saw
you are a great fan.
- I'm into this stuff, I am.
- This is an addition to your collection.
- I love it.
(laughter)
I love it.
This is fantastic.
- Welcome to Malaysia.
- Thank you so much.
This is fantastic.
Super cool.
- Is your sister here?
- Yes, she's right there.
(laughter)
(people talking over one another)
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- I think block chain is
like running a marathon.
The longest marathon of your life.
I think the best way
to train for a marathon
is to get on a treadmill every day.
To run a couple of 5ks.
I think the only thing a
big company can actually do
to get themselves ready for
the real war of technology
is marketing.
Cause it's, your spending it now.
It's not like you have
to go buy a thintech
and overpay, right?
Because everything's overpriced, right?
The, and I, and then think about why
I think this is so practical.
I also think in parallel.
I think most big companies are wasting
90 cents on the dollar on
their current marketing.
So to me it's like triple a good idea.
To completely transform your marketing
capabilities, team,
infrastructure, partners,
internal, external.
Yet, if you look at the early examples,
they're very practical.
I'm a businessman.
I'm not a futurist or a pundit.
This is all practitioner shit.
This is all practical.
This is about driving business results.
- I always look at his Instagram.
(laughter)
- It's like you're real life of Instagram.
- And I'm a true believer of empathy
you were talking about then.
- Thank you.
It's very real.
And you know what?
Empathy is what we're talking about.
All this comes?
Be empathetic to where
people's attention is.
And again, look,
you are the target and you're telling me
you're a great fan on Instagram.
They're on there.
You are watching me on Instagram.
Yet as an executive,
you're trying to debate
is the person you're reaching on there.
I see this every day.
(laughter)
You know?
- The old blinders, right?
- Because what happens is
as a human, you're a human.
But as soon as you come into the office,
you transform your mindset.
Happens all the time.
- So we're gonna?
- Photo, yes.
No problem.
- Can I please just have one?
I just gotta get one.
This is great.
- I don't talk too many different things.
I believe in, I believe
in what I believe in.
You know?
I think the crazy part is people don't do.
People don't do.
You know?
- Listen to (mumbling).
- Oh, they're in.
- They're in.
- Hi.
- Jerry.
How are you doing?
- I'm doing very good.
- Sandy Clark from the Star Newspaper.
- Such a pleasure, Sandy.
How are you?
- I'm good, thanks.
- Good.
Wanna go over here?
- Yeah.
And she said, what's the one thing
businesses and colleges and universities
can do for young people now
to prepare them for the
future of what's to come?
- By recognizing that
they're fundamentally broken
in what they're educating
them on right now.
- Okay.
- And I think that takes
humility and empathy.
You know, I have a lot of respect for
education systems and companies.
But they have to recognize
that the curriculum
that we are pushing down
our employee's and student's throats
9 our of 10 times is outdated at best.
And completely and in
outer space of the reality
of the marketplace at worst.
I think we're not preparing
people for success
because a lot of times it's
not in our vested interest.
- But how do you do that?
You hear so much talk
about chase your passion,
find your success, make that journey.
What is it specifically--
- But that's an ideology.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- To me, I'm talking about practically.
- In another sense than that.
- You know, in a practicality standpoint,
if you're teaching students things.
For example, if you're
teaching in any matter
that is predicated on
memorization, that is laughable.
- Yeah.
- Let's start there.
- Every single piece of
education in the world
that sits with memorization
should be eliminated.
Because information is a commodity.
It sits on your phone.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Hey Siri, who's the 19th
president of the United States?
(phone dinging)
To me,
- [Siri On Phone] Here's
what I found on the web for
who's the 19th president
of the United States.
Have a look.
- The fact that I know
that Rutherford B. Hayes
is the 19th president of the
United States that quickly?
Makes me laugh at every school in America
that's making kids memorize
the presidents of the United States.
- Yeah.
- It's lazy.
And so I think we do a lot of that.
And so what would I say?
In the same way that
companies manage people.
And don't let them post on social media.
Like, it's crazy.
- Yeah, that's a huge thing.
- And then it extends
to the furthest thing.
All these parents that aren't letting
their kids spend a lot
of time on the screen.
What world do you think
your kid's going to live in?
Your kids gonna live
in a fucking computer.
- Yeah.
- It's gonna be, the
screen's gonna be in them.
And you're, you're worried
about their screen time?
For that?
So they can read a book?
Like literally the device that's
delivering the information
is your passion?
All those parents that don't
let their kids play video games
meanwhile their kids could have become
the most successful e-sports players?
- Yeah.
- We fear monger the future
and we over respect the past.
- Yeah.
- We fear the future and we over respect
over respect the past.
The past is the past.
Nobody's going in a time machine.
So, you know, I would say
education and businesses
have a very common thing.
They over respect the past.
Wow.
I mean, we god plenty
of time there, D-Rock.
- [D-Rock] Yeah, whatever
you want for the vlog.
- Oh vlog.
What's up, vlog?
I don't talk to you that much.
I appreciate you guys.
I really, really appreciate you guys.
Especially, I've been reading
a lot of the comments lately.
Super interesting on the
nuances you guys pick up.
Appreciate it.
What I love about the
vlog more than anything
is just the complete body of work.
The consistency and just a grind.
It is what it is.
Pounding those same themes.
It's so interesting to see
how many of you do two core
things that interest me.
One, you hear the same thing the
97th time in a different way.
And it was the moment.
Because you were ready for it.
And number two, really been enjoying
the people who have been
flying back in after doing
80 days or 100 days of being summer, off,
or watching something else,
or hustling on sometime and coming back
and seeing the value and the consistency.
That's been super humbling
when you guys make that reference.
So I appreciate it.
("In my Feelings" by Drake)
(laughter)
- Do you know there's a
lot of people in this room
who have a passion but
the reason they won't
leave their job right now is not
because they can't afford it,
but because they don't
want to take a step back
to take three steps forward.
There are people in
this room who will live
the next 45 years of their life unhappy
because they wanted to extra
bedrooms in their house
that they will never use.
I'm being dead serious.
You so care what other
people think of you,
you're not willing to sell your home
and go live in a neighborhood
that's not as nice,
drive a car that's not as nice,
to start a business that
will make you happy.
And so you will stay at your job
for another 21 years that you hate
just to pay for the facade of success.
Of people's opinions that you value more
than your own happiness.
That fucks with me like
you would not believe.
It blows my mind that most of the world
is willing to live their life
completely predicated on the
judgment of other people.
The reason you're not winning
and doing what you want
is somebody's opinion of you matters more
than your opinion of yourself.
Somebody's opinion of
you matters more to you
than your your opinion of yourself.
- [Audience Member] Agreed!
(applause)
- It's very true.
And I'm so desperate
how, you know, okay cool.
I'm up here, I'm on stage,
we're inspired for a second,
you're pumped, you're like, yeah, fuck it.
I'm gonna call my dad
and tell him fuck you.
(laughter)
You know?
The problem is, usually
between right this moment
and when you get home to
make that call, it wears off.
(laughter)
Right?
And so people ask me,
why do I keep talking?
Why do I keep putting up vlogs?
Why do I keep doing my podcast?
Why do you keep saying this?
You know, some people yell at me,
you know, Gary, you keep
saying the same things.
Yes, I believe in them.
What, am I supposed to make up something
I don't believe in to talk about?
Yes, I believe in it.
Because I know for some of you,
you've watched three
years of my video content
and maybe this talk, because
we're in the same room,
is the one.
Maybe it's not.
Maybe you don't even know who I am
and this is the first time
and then you go watch, start
listening to my podcast.
And 19 months from now,
I'll say the same shit I just said here.
But maybe because of the
night before, and the weather,
and because it was audio instead of video,
it clicks.
Because that's how this works.
You have one life.
And the most scary thing
for me in the world
is the look of regret on
somebody whose over 80 years old.
The scariest thing in the world to me
in my bones that I feel
is when I meet somebody over 80 years old
and they have regret on their face.
Because time is running out
and there's not a lot more they can do.
When I look at this audience,
the far majority under 60,
you've got a fuckload more time.
And here is the most interesting part.
And this is just the most
fascinating thing about life.
Everything that happened yesterday back,
everything that happened yesterday back,
means nothing.
(applause)
(foreign language)
- Thank you, thank you.
- I'll do a couple.
("Nothing's Gonna Stop Us" by Starship)
(audience talking over one another)
(emcee speaking, unintelligible)
- Bye guys.
The problem is living, living your life
based on somebody else's
KPIs is devastating.
It's devastating.
It will never work out in the end.
I'd rather parents and kids
fight for the first three years
than fight for the last three years.
Once you acknowledge it,
just don't lie to yourself.
Like once you stop lying to yourself.
Once you start blaming yourself,
owning yourself, being yourself about it,
then it is what it is.
Then it changes everything.
It takes the leverage
away from anybody else.
And leverage is what
people need to focus on.
Because when you're
doing something because
you don't have the leverage,
that's devastating.
Like, that was kind of
the most interesting
part of this talk.
Which was like, alright,
here's what you came for.
It's two minutes.
Now let's got to what you need.
This is what you think you need.
Let me tell you what you need.
How are you gonna post on social
media when you're insecure?
(laughter)
how are you gonna post 8 times a day
when you don't know how to take feedback?
I can tell you everything
to do on LinkedIn.
But if you're scared to write that article
because you're scared to
get fired from your job?
Just going though my own process
of trying to figure our
how the fuck to help.
It's not super complicated, you know?
- [Security] Sorry, sorry, no photos.
(crowd talking over one another)
- Okay, can we have the presenters up?
- Thank you for coming
man, thanks for being here.
How are you?
Nice to meet you.
Hey brother.
- Your work's changed my life.
I really enjoy listening to it.
- Thank you so much.
- [Audience Member] I have a question.
How can you decide what to do
when you like a lot of stuff?
- You pick one.
- [Audience Member] You
don't waste your time?
- You pick one.
- [Audience Member] How do you
know which is the right one?
- You don't.
(laughter)
You don't.
And let me tell you a
very, very important thing.
I believe one of the most
fascinating excuses in life
is that I'm so good at so many things
that I don't know which one to pick.
I think it's an excuse
and I think it's ego
and I think it's a vulnerability.
I think it's bullshit.
I really do.
Pick one.
If you're so good at so many things,
you'll pick one, you'll be good at that,
and you can do a bunch of things.
I'm doing a bunch of things.
I don't want to waste time
because I'm so good at so many things
is an excuse to not do.
And it's the worst one because
you're trying to act cool
while not doing anything.
(gentle laughter)
I mean it man.
Pick something and fucking do it.
You're a fucking young kid.
You can do all 19 things.
- [Audience Member] Got it.
- You got it.
You're welcome.
Cheers.
(audience talking in muffled tones)
Where's my sis?
I think we should title it,
"When You're Good at Too Many Things."
I think we should slow play them in.
Because a lot of people think that's them.
That's me!
(laughter)
And then they get to,
millions will we destroyed on Instagram.
I'm really glad I ran into you.
Listen to that.
- Thank you man, thank you so much.
- It's real.
Just pick one.
Right?
- That was the biggest
assignment all weekend.
- It is.
That is it.
Thank you.
It's an undercover excuse.
You know what I mean?
- Thank you so much.
- And when you don't care what others.
The biggest thing that's interesting to me
about that excuse is
that it's the ultimate
caring about other people's opinion.
Because you're positioning
it as, you know what I mean?
Just do something and don't
give a fuck if you fail.
They all fail too.
- Alright, peace man.
- Going right.
Go to the right.
That's where.
- It was nice meeting you.
- [Producer] That sounds like serendipity.
- That's serendipity.
(speaking foreign language)
- Good to see you vlog.
Thank you my friend.
Thank you guys.
- This way.
- That was crazy, right?
Good evening.
One could say I was tough on that kid.
When he said, you know, that
he's good at so many things.
Like you know, most people are.
- He came back.
What did he say?
- He said that was the biggest
thing he took from the day.
He's like, that helped
me more than anything.
The weekend.
Because here's why.
By the way, I don't like it.
I hate negativity.
I don't want to give him that advice.
But it's the truth.
And I know the truth is always the best.
The truth is when you say,
I'm too good at too many things,
and I don't know which one to pick
not to waste my time,
it means you're not.
- How long have you
been watching my stuff?
- I've been watching two years, minimum.
(speaking in foreign language)
- And what was the biggest thing
that you learned in this time
that you did not pick
up in those two years?
(speaking in foreign language)
- Gary, the most I learn
is giving value content.
Because all this while I think I'm giving,
I think I'm not giving enough as you.
- Cause there's , cause
there's still a little
that you're holding back
for whatever reason.
- Yes.
And
- I get it, I get it.
- That's the real, that is a real asset.
Attention equals to asset.
- Mm-hmm.
Currency.
- Currency.
(speaking in foreign language)
I really don't really get the content yet.
- I get it, it's early.
- But after the dinner, I really get it.
- Yeah, I get it.
- [Photographer] One, two, five.
- Take care.
Bye bye, bye bye.
This way?
- [Producer] Yeah, they're
going somewhere else.
- So 7:45 down here?
Yeah.
Than you my friend.
Take care of yourself.
(club music playing)
Thank you, hello everyone.
Hello, how are you?
Nice to meet you.
(crowd talking over one another)
- Gary, nice to meet you.
- Hi Carrie John, nice to meet you.
- So nice to meet you.
- Hey, what's up, Kylie, good to meet you.
- Good to see you.
- Francesca.
- [Gary] Hi Francesca, how are you?
- Hi, I'm Drew.
Good to meet you.
- [Gary] How are you, man?
- Hi, Issac.
- Issac.
- Hi, Daniel.
- Such a pleasure.
I'm an entrepreneur.
And I've done a lot of the things
that are being talked about here.
Two core things that are
like, being the operator
or being the facilitator of the operation.
I've done a lot of investing,
I've done a lot of business running.
I've done a lot of content creation.
And the craziest part I think
something that will be
valuable for the whole crew
like, it's so crazy how much
has been liven in this room.
Only surpassed by how much
life we all have left.
And I think it's, I'm really
fascinated by perspective.
I'm starting to realize a lot
more than I even realized.
And I think the most
interesting perspective
is calibrating time.
Cause it is a fucking thing for all of us.
Like, I really wish, as a matter of fact
I just thought of something
for the first time in my life.
I never until this moment
wanted to know the day that I died.
Like if we went around the right now
and did the game of, do you
want to know the day you die?
Like if you could know.
Most people, and even I
up until 40 seconds ago,
would say no.
- [Woman] Deep thought.
- [Crowd] Yeah!
- It's an interesting thought.
And I would tell you literally literally
up until like a minute ago
when I started talking, I never wanted to.
And I'm wondering if now I would take it.
Only because I think time
is like a really funny one.
I don't know, perspective is
super on my mind these days
and I just wish I think
everybody's impatient.
Like staggeringly it is the
shortcoming of most people.
And I wish people would be more patient.
Because if you would,
you'd be so much happier.
Um, so.
Not enough conversation about how
fucked up parenting is in Asia.
I think the most interesting thing to me
is what I struggle with with parenting
is accelerating in Asia.
Like, it's unbelievable how
it's unbelievable how much parents
view children as their product.
And as a reflection of
them in this global market.
And I'm being obviously generalizing.
But it is unbelievable unhealthy.
It's unbelievably unhealthy.
- [Male] So adding onto
that, one of my questions
I like to ask people over here is,
how can you accept yourself?
And the analogy to that is,
I think a lot of people
can't accept themselves here
because they can't accept their parents.
For this exact same reason.
- Couldn't agree with you more.
I think the best way to accept yourself
is to not hear anybody else.
T's a lot easier.
Like to me, everybody else sucks too.
Like everybody else is
bad at something too.
I don't understand
dwelling on your weaknesses
in a world where others
have other weaknesses.
Fake environments.
When you live in a world
that you can't afford.
Because you're keeping
up with the Joneses.
Scary shit.
Poison.
Lot of people running
big credit cards here
to look right in their environment.
Piyong, it's Gary V.
I'm here with your less handsome brother.
(laughter)
Happy, happy fucking birthday.
I'm so proud of you man.
Keep doing your thing.
Thank you so much for watching the videos.
Much love.
- Perfect, thanks.
He's gonna find it.
- Awesome.
- Cool.
- Thank you, thank you for Masha.
Thanks for sharing so much.
- Of course.
It's like really great.
- [Photographer] Okay, one, two, three.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much.
That was really cool.
I was expecting startups and marketing.
But this conversation about
families and fake realities?
- The foundation.
- It's really, you know one
thing I've been saying now
it's like this conversation
on fake environments
it's an eye opener.
Because it works both ways.
Quick, my dad lost his job at some point.
And I realize after this conversation
that they created a fake reality
around him losing his job.
That I never thought of as a fake reality.
Like to me, I'm glad that,
that was always a
positive story in my life.
And today I look back and I realize
the anger I had in
college for having to work
and put myself through that
was because of that fake reality.
- Yeah.
- 100%.
- If they hadn't created that situation.
- You would have understood it better.
- I would have understood it better.
I would have understood the hustle.
- 100%
- I wouldn't have felt
cheated when I was 17.
- 100%, 100%.
- And that was beautiful.
Because I'd never seen.
- 100%
- Because I always look at the rich kids
and I was like, you have a fake reality.
I don't have one, because I hustle.
- Right.
- But now I'm like, fuck no.
- Everyone has your own.
- I had my fake reality.
- And by the way, I haven't
gotten to this part yet.
But I know it exists.
Some fake realities are different
and better and, you know.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- It's perspective.
- Like my hustle comes
from that fake reality.
- Correct.
But it might have come in a healthier way.
- It might have come in a healthier way.
That's it, that's it.
- Like today, walking in here.
I still feel like, oh, look at
all these impressive people.
- Bro, me too though.
That comes out of a healthy one.
- Yeah.
- It's respect.
- It's admiration of others.
- Yeah.
- It's humility of like,
I know what's happening with me, but what?
There's plenty of people
doing better things,
different things, tying it, you know.
- Yeah.
- It could have come in a healthier way.
That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- Powerful insights
man, thank you so much.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
We were leaving and the next one get in.
Have a great night.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
- Bye bye.
Take care.
- I'm looking forward to
the Alexa telling your game.
- Tell them I'll see you on Tuesday.
- [Photographer] There we go.
- Take care bud.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
- Dinner was a lot of fun, man.
Take care of yourself.
- Thank you so much.
- Can we have a picture with you?
Okay, one more.
- Can I get one?
- Sure.
- Enjoy Malaysia.
- Thank you.
- Very good to meet you, brother.
My name's Rico.
- Thank you my man.
- Love you.
- Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Take care everyone.
- Have a good night.
- Nice meeting all of you.
(quiet, gentle music)